I mean is this country of 350 million
people only capable of being governed by
two families in the in the whole in his
whole country
I have Nikhil SP with reason TV and
today we are sitting down with Gary
Johnson he was the 2012 Libertarian
Party candidate for president of the
United States is a two-term former
governor of New Mexico as a Republican
and he's now heading up a pot company
called cannabis sativa Gary thanks for
talking to us
Nick great being here thank you let's
talk about cannabis sativa yeah very
exciting uh well publicly-traded we're
publicly traded and the stock symbol is
CBDs
we're at about a 12-month low on the
stock but I understand that we're a
start-up and the idea is we intend to
brand the best marijuana products in the
world under the trademark hi small H
small I we've trademarked that okay we
think we're gonna do a billion dollars
in schwag sales eventually because
you're gonna put our sticker on the side
of your car because it's a chai and it
really says it all because that way the
police can pull me over more quickly
that's that'll be the downside of
potentially putting a high stick around
let's talk about the market of you know
legal pot I mean at this point pot is a
recreational pot is legal in three
states in four states four states and
the District of Columbia it's legal in
24 states medicinally biggest obstacle
when it comes to marijuana industry
right now is in those 24 states and
those four states recreationally every
product manufactured in those states has
to be grown processed and packaged in
those individual states that is not the
best scenario for the consumer and
that's because the federal law it's so
exact exactly so you can't cross state
lines with any of these products and
that ends up like I say to be at this
point the the biggest obstacle I guess
Ohio has a pot legalization initiative
in the fall of this year California is
going to be having it on the ballot when
do you think enough states will have
gone to recreational pot legalization
where the feds will either actually make
their stand or just be like okay it's
over well so here's my crystal ball my
crystal ball is first of all I think
we've reached the tipping point okay the
walls it's falling do
but when it actually crashes my
prediction is is 2016 California at the
ballot box makes recreational sales
legally and then I believe that
overnight 20 states overnight will
legislate it and governors will sign it
and that that will genuinely be the you
know wall around in terms of certifying
or trade marking pot what do you think
customers are looking for in this type
of stuff well right now more than
anything people are just looking to buy
the products and get high I mean that's
really what they're looking for but when
you when you look forward I mean what
people really want is coca-cola the
coca-cola tastes the same here because
it's the same ingredients here as it is
in Thailand McDonald's you know hey when
McDonald's started out you have to
believe that the french fries maybe
didn't taste the same from one state to
another because they hadn't standardized
it but this is going to be the evolution
of the industry and the evolution of the
industry is gonna be these quality
products that really genuinely you
you're gonna know the contents and
you're gonna be assured of that
consistency and safety then this is
blending into also a kind of moment
where everything is artisanal or you
know I think about when you go into a
wine shop or a cheese shop you have
people there who will say okay well this
is from this area and it has these
qualities but you know the alcohol
content that the pot potency the THC
potency will your products or your
trademarks will cover all all of that
sort all of that sort of stuff and you
draw a great analogy I mean one pot crop
even though it's the same strain from
one year to the next just like wine it
ends up to be different products we want
to be consistently we want to be the
dawn Perry and I'm thinking about this
as somebody who grew up in the 70s and
80s where you never knew what you were
smoking you had no idea executive that
whether it was like you know kitty
litter or you know parsley mixed with
this and that and oregano how long will
it take to generate the information that
people want or that they don't even know
that they want right now for example
most people don't know that there are
two kinds of pot sativa we
is clean your house marijuana with a
smile on your face or indica which is go
to sleep marijuana when you when you
look at the prohibition model that we
have right now everything that we've
consumed in our lives has really been a
combination of the two
now with legalization you can separate
this and and and you can get refined
highs that end up competing against
illegal drugs I mean this is really and
I've always well as legal ones right
exactly well I've always maintained that
marijuana is much safer than alcohol one
of the another big issue is impairment
the is that that first of all we need to
establish impairment levels in
Washington and Colorado state five
nanograms is considered DUI I'm gonna
butcher his name ross Rigga Baldy
Canadian snowboarder wins the gold medal
in a snowboard Vancouver tests at
fifteen nanograms after his gold medal
rung are we saying that you can win a
gold medal at triple the DUI level
existing in Colorado and Washington
State big issue I don't know what the
impairment level is but I'm gonna guess
that maybe on the nanogram level maybe
it's ninety nanograms but it's certainly
not five yeah so what kind of
interactions are you having from legal
high companies meaning like you know
anheuser-busch Coors are they kind of
like that you know you guys this is it's
totally different you know and like
you're a problem or are they getting on
board what I said for years was people
would come up to me and say I hope I
hope arowana gets legalized because then
I'm gonna get in the marijuana business
I'm gonna make a fortune and everybody
can make a fortune in marijuana because
everybody smoked marijuana that's the
expertise that everybody has and they
know that given that expertise they can
make money sure but I've always said
you're not going to compete against r.j.
Reynolds you're just not going to
compete against the companies that are
in fact going to enter in this space
will come to find out none of those
companies none of those big companies
have entered into this at all zero they
haven't dipped their toe in the
they're gonna do is they're gonna buy
the top they're gonna come in and
they're gonna buy what is established as
the best and they're gonna spend
billions of dollars in doing that but
but that point is still many years and
you're not seeing any negative effects
from kind of the alcohol beverage
community of like pushing back not at
this thing not at they've given up that
goes well I think they've given up that
ghost and and yet it is very real I mean
there there are people that are going to
prefer marijuana over alcohol and like I
say I that is personally there's
something wrong with alcohol personally
marijuana you know anything in excess is
doesn't work anything in moderation you
know it certainly works are you guys
developing products I mean in terms of
smokeable vapors and edibles most for
the most part we're doing the edible
side of this and interestingly in
Colorado sales of recreational marijuana
about it's about 70 percent edible 30
percent smoke when Colorado started out
as a medicinal state it started out at
about 65 smoke 35 edible and now on on
the medical side in Colorado edible has
now surpassed smoke yeah so that's the
future well let's talk about our America
initiative that's the nonprofit that you
run where you raise topics for
discussion how are you doing with that
and what are your main interests these
days well the main interest is providing
a voice that's not being that's not
being stated out there I mean I'm often
asked oh well what are your differences
with rand paul my only differences drug
policy marriage equality military
intervention wonderful words but of
course you know he's gonna add add to
military spending immigration he wants
to build a fence across the wall and
abortion other than those five topics I
think Rand Paul and I are probably on on
target but those are not small minor
issues yeah so is that it what our
America is talking about those types all
those issues reflect I think I think
that what's coming out of my mouth is
reflective of most Americans speaking
with a broad brushstroke
nobody is a fiscal conservative and a
flaming social liberal run I am and I'm
that voice and I know and I think the
majority of Americans fall in that
category so are you gonna run for
libertarian hopes of it I hope so
you know what has to happen to coax you
well maybe maybe it's something
unforeseen that prevents it from
happening but at this point it is
something that I would like to do I'm
not announcing because I just think
there are more downsides than upsides to
announcing at this point and and look I
don't have any delusions about the
process
during the last the four years that I
spent trying to become president United
States in the last cycle in retrospect
ninety percent of the time I spent doing
that ended up to be wasted time Nick
right now I'm not repeating any of the
90 percent expecting different results
I'm looking at the 10 percent I know
what works and it's it's a whole
different my anxiety level is is greatly
diminished talk a little bit about your
migration from the Republican Party to
the libertarian party because you were a
popular two-term governor of New Mexico
elected both times and you you were not
a lifelong politician but you know why
did you leave the Republican Party and
you ran originally for president you
tried to get the Republican nomination
already left me I mean just left me
flapping in the wind the media was
saying that to be in the debates that
you had to be at 2% and then they would
list four polls where he would have to
be at 2% well Nick I would I would have
only been in one of those four polls or
none of those four polls I wouldn't have
even been listed and presented this to
the Republican Party that you know what
the Republican Party here is being
manipulated in ways that real
go unnoticed by everyone you need to
stand up for fairness not necessarily
for me but just for fairness and they
turn my back on that I do believe that I
am representative of Republican thought
but the conspiracy out there is not is
not not letting Gary Johnson on stage
the conspiracy out there is promoting
candidates like Donald Trump that the
world ends up looking CNN I saw the
other day CNN the head of CNN says we're
not gonna give Donald Trump any time
whatsoever cameras off
we want to give them as much time as we
possibly can because the world is gonna
look at this as just being kooky and
whoever the eventual nominee is will be
painted because of Donald Trump in that
same light Michele Bachmann Rick
Santorum in 2012 same thing talk about
Trump do you think that Trump represents
anything legitimate in the Republican
Party or among the American politics
well he like number two he is he is
appealing to a segment that I'll just
label racist and and it exists and it's
out there and you know what I don't want
to have anything to do with it I don't
wanna have anything to do with it it
embarrasses it embarrasses me and like I
say I think that the electorate will
paint the entire Republican Party with
with a broad brush as a result of Trump
and it won't be a positive and because
he's deported the Mexicans they'll have
to paint the round three and he employs
tens of thousands of people and he's in
the service industry how many of those
are immigrants how many of those III I
don't I don't get why any of them remain
around talk a little bit about
immigration because I know it's a big
topic for our America and it's it's a
real hot button issue in American
politics
what inflames people and you were the
governor of a border state what inflames
people is the notion that somehow
they're taking that they're coming over
the border illegally and they're
siphoning off or living off our welfare
system well that's a fallacy I mean it
sounds logical actually there's a logic
to it but it's not the reality these are
hardly cream-of-the-crop workers that
are coming over from Mexico
when you've got all of the Republican
candidates talking about building a
fence across the border that is just
whacko
we should make it as easy as possible
for somebody that wants it coming across
the border to work to get a work visa
abolish income tax abolish corporate tax
eliminate the IRS and you know what
we're gonna need tens of millions of
immigrants to fill the jobs that will
exist in this country as a result of
zero corporate tax what do you do if you
you know about the the illegal immigrant
who had been found guilty of various
crimes and then committed a murder
because this now right after Trump
talked about how oh you know all these
bad Mexicans come across then you have
that how you know why is that not a
legitimate rejoinder to an open borders
it is a legitimate resounding immigrants
both illegal and legal are much more law
observing than US citizens that's
statistical now within that realm of
course you have those instances but the
overall statistic much much less as
governor of New Mexico I saw a lot of
immigrants that were going to be
deported because they had committed
crimes I will tell you that any prior
violent crime I allowed that deportation
to take place including DUI because I
didn't want to see an immigrant who had
been arrested for DUI and had previous
arrest for DUI
at some point killing someone in the
future outside of that I I didn't allow
any of these deportations to occur
Hillary Clinton seems to have almost a
clear path not quite but almost a clear
path to the Democratic nomination would
she be a good president by your account
well she's gonna be a continuation of
status quo I mean to me Republicans
Democrats Tweedledee Tweedledum Jeb Bush
you know just yesterday I saw where he'd
raised a hundred and seventeen million
dollars I mean is this country of three
hundred and fifty million people only
capable of being governed by two
families
in the hole in this whole country the
biggest factor in politics is name
familiarity and that's the phenomenon
that's that exists right now Jeb Bush is
gonna end up being the nominee
substantively what's your beef with
Hillary substantively that really it's
much to do about nothing that it is
status quo that it's that it's that it's
genuinely not anything different it's
it's holding the office as is the case
with most politicians it's it's holding
the office as opposed to actually doing
something while you're in office if you
were to become president what would be
the you know first two or three things
that you would do well I think the
biggest threat to our way of life I
believe is the fact that we need to
balance the federal budget that we
cannot continue to spend more money than
what we take in and that at some point
this will result in a monetary collapse
and that is not going to be a pretty
scene it's gonna be ugly so you've got
balancing the budget at the top of the
list what else well when you talk about
balancing the budget that's really
encompassing I mean you you you talk
about what else
well that's reform to Medicaid that's
reform to Medicare
that's cutting military spending you
can't balance the federal budget unless
you deal with those three issues are you
optimistic about America's future in the
planets future or are you pessimist
I am absolutely optimistic or I wouldn't
be in this but but it's so disheartening
that we're gonna have a bush in the
White House or we're gonna have Clinton
in the White House what is there to
believe that anything changes and that
the number one problem facing the
country is gets addressed no there's
none there's none and yet you remain
optimistic well I do I mean I'm an
optimistic human being and that's just
who I am I mean I can't I can't deny my
identity and you're the CEO of a
cannabis company I mean how a reverence
can you possibly be how much [ __ ] you
know talk about a dream job I mean
really well we will leave it there we
are talking with Gary Johnson he's the
CEO of
sativa a drug of pot company a legal pot
company Zasa the head of the our America
initiative which raises all sorts of
issues from different and libertarian
points of view and he may well be the he
may well be throwing his hat into the
presidential campaign for 2016 now just
just as an end to this also you're
showing a bit of a reverence aren't you
by not wearing your leather jacket
it's a reverence all the way around I
didn't think it ever came on yeah well
maybe it's on it's just not visible